invasion of the body snatchers there's
no way they're going to turn this into
teen drama this is no way why
would they ever do that the host so the
host is the story it's like the
aftermath of an invasion of the body
snatchers type scenario where the
invasion isn't happening it's already
happened and we already lost they say
that with a voiceover in the beginning
of this movie it's like oh our world is
fine there's no crime everyone's pretty
docile everyone trusts each other
everything is at peace the only thing
it's not our world aliens invaded and
they're parasites invaded everyone's
bodies and now we're just not us anymore
that for a select few people and I was
like that's cool
turns out I was wrong it's middle school
the story is the girl from The
Lovely Bones she's all grown up now she
was part of her resistance she throws
herself out of a window
she splats on the grounds of the like
okay we'll just use her body and we have
another one and now her eyes change and
she's an alien now the only thing is
inside her head she's still conscious
she can hear her inside her head talking
to the alien consciousness who is you
know in the body so the alien chick is
going around doing her thing and you can
hear her talking with her and arguing
with her and eventually of course the
alien chicks going to empathize with her
and that's all fine and dandy although
at that point I was like this movie's
the premise is okay but the execution
there were a lot of flashbacks of
her with her old boyfriend you're like
okay is this movie a series of
flashbacks is that it we have a movie
that is just built all on flashbacks and
that ends and then we truck along and
you're just like why is this happening
come on get to the resistance let's see
some fighting so they get to the
resistance and you're like oh crap
anothers the boyfriend who hates the
chick because that's the alien invaded
body version of his old girlfriend but
now this guy is in love with the alien
chick and then inner monologue and
it's not a love triangle it's like a
love for gee it's a box this person
loved this person who this person used
to be but is actually still inside her
head and this person loves this person
in that alien chick is that's the thing
to do nowadays you take any monster
movie from the old days werewolves
mummies zombies vampires now aliens
doesn't matter and you turn it into teen
romance which is a bummer because a
movie like this could be an interesting
thing if they didn't turn it into teen
romance why can't you keep teen romance
in high school where it belongs I mean
if this promise
happened in a high school I'd be like
it's not good but it is where it belongs
you start bringing it into the realm of
alien invasion I'm just like why do you
give it that coat of paint I mean just
the dialogue wasn't believable either
come on you can push the dialogue a
little bit it's the end of the world
alien invasion you're obviously a chick
with a little bit of attitude stuck
inside your own head so when she's doing
inner monologue why didn't she just lose
her and be like you know what
that's
take the nicest sweetest person ever
they're nice and sweet because they
don't actually say curse words to other
people but if it's inside their own head
they think it this movie should be rated
R on dialogue alone no never cuss is the
entire movie stuff like that I'm just
like is unbelievable and as much as teen
romance is kind of the thing nowadays
and we've seen a lot of it there were a
couple of them that I actually did dig
his movies I was like all right so I'm
not completely against that kind of
thing if it's executed in a way that is
good when I was watching this movie I
was like of the Twilight ripoffs this is
the one that most closely resembles
Twilight at that point I did not know
that the book this movie is based off of
was written by Stephenie Meyer the
author of Twilight then I saw that in
the end credits and I was like
everything just came together and makes
perfect sense now I can't stress this
enough even though the premise the
overall premise of the movie an alien
invasion thing could be interesting the
execution was choppy the characters are
terrible there is not one character in
this movie that you end up giving a
about this is one point where this kid
is in mortal danger and you're like so I
mean of terrible movies that I see
there's usually one scene at least in
one relation with a person where I'm
like alright that's touching enough this
movie I had none of that I felt like a
really hollow shelled out bastard
something good did come out of this
movie the chick from The Lovely Bones
got hot good job movie for showing me
that I walked out of this movie the
security guy was like so what'd you
watch I told him he was like not even
worth $0.99 I was like no because at
that point you're still paying two hours
of your life this movie is not worth
that just wasn't buying or digging any
of it I will say the host is dog I
can apparently by a zombie romance I can
by witchcraft romance choppy alien
invasion romance with inner monologue in
the head of someone else as where I draw
the line I guess but in a mocking way if
you had to change something into teen
romance what would it be me mortal
kombat because I'm an I guess
but you know something like that
whatever it is comment below
me now I really wouldn't do mortal
combat I would never turn that new teen
romance not ever and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more